the wind's coming from behind me uh the
camera might get rained on
uh if i look tired it's because i am uh
this video ended up being a disaster
there's
no other word to describe it but i have
traveled too far and expanded too much
energy
to throw it away entirely and i have
learned quite a bit of stuff about how
iceland is handling tourists
flocking to its new and dangerous
volcano so
from the outskirts of reykjavik airport
here's a story that didn't work how i
expected it to uh but which i hope
is still interesting first things first
iceland has a new volcano and it's close
to the airport and relatively easy to
get to
so the plan was film a video with a
flowing river of
lava behind me and as the plane's
landing i can i can sort of see
the volcano out of the window uh there
was a lot of low fog and it was all a
bit fuzzy
uh but the volcano was clearly erupting
so early the next morning i meet up with
bjorn who's my guide and drone pilot
he's
very very good at his job i've got him
for one day and one day only he's
working on a dozen other projects all
over iceland this month
uh we drive the 45 minutes to the
volcano site and then walk along one of
the tourist trails up the mountainside
um i took a bit of uh video as we went
uh we've got to head up the
ridgeline you can see in the distance in
that shot it's a bit of a steep climb at
the start but it's very possible you can
see silhouettes of people up on the
ridge and there were folks of
all ages going up to to see lava uh it
takes about 90 minutes of steady
climbing give or take
sometimes we're overtaking slower
tourists sometimes we are getting out
the way so that runners from a climbing
race can speed past us
i've like no idea how they managed to
run the downhill bit without slipping on
loose rocks but
anyway uh we get to an overlook point
and that's not the volcano it's just
where the lava spills over into another
valley uh when there's
too much lava like like water out an
overflowing bath
and that view is our first bit of bad
news because just a few hours earlier
there was active flowing red hot lava
there you could see it on the webcams
that various
companies have set up now solid rock uh
and bjorn sends up the drone to see
what's happening uh
uh that's his volcano drone by the way
it's a little bit melted in a couple
places from uh too many close encounters
with lava
uh and the drone goes over the main
basin
and then over the crater itself and the
pictures that it sends back
show the volcano is completely quiet it
has just
stopped we keep climbing anyway uh over
the next ridge to the main overlook
point
a few hours earlier we would have seen
fountains of lava exploding from the
main crater and flowing through the
valley
uh we could have climbed down and stood
i mean maybe not next to it but a few
meters away
uh but as it is there's just a lot of
disappointed tourists
looking at some rock uh so at this point
i need to introduce you to the graph
the graph is data from the iceland
meteorological officers sensors
and they track the rumblings at certain
frequencies at all the seismic locations
around iceland
so when the graph of this volcano is
high it's erupting when it's low it's
quiet it's been erupting for a long time
now
bjorn shows me the graph on his phone
and it's clear at 5am the volcano just
stopped for some reason and activity is
low and it's trending downwards there
will be no new lava for
maybe for just the day or maybe it's all
over and it will never erupt again
uh but okay like i can still make the
best of this we head down into the
valley
next uh next next to the cool lava uh so
the bit i was sitting on was just
slightly warm and while we knew that it
was safe like there were
other parts where there would be
semi-liquid rock just underneath
ready to kill you uh earlier on we'd
look down we'd spotted a couple of
just fools walking out across the lava
don't do that anyway we set up i make
some adjustments to my script i try to
rehearse my icelandic pronunciation a
bit
which is not good and we start
in march 2021 sorry i screwed that line
up let's do that again sorry
in march 2021 after months of rumblings
and warning
signs vagra dal seattle this volcano in
iceland
finally erupted and well
it's not quite as dramatic as you might
hope you will have noticed that there's
not actually
any moving or spraying lava behind me
the volcano is
not performing today i've been unlucky
i'm not saying don't come to the
icelandic volcano but
this is unpredictable and unpredictable
things that spew molten rock
aren't exactly safe but i'm not here to
talk about the volcano itself
the question i've got is how do the
folks in charge of this area deal with
an
unexpected unpredictable and potentially
lethal
new tourist attraction because that was
going to be the main point of the video
i didn't just want to go
oh volcano because because lots of
people have done that
i want to talk about the infrastructure
around it i've got interviews set up the
next day
uh with someone from the icelandic
government's civil
defense and emergency management
department i've probably got those words
in the wrong order uh and we're the
geologist
and i know that bjorn can provide some
shots of what the volcano looks like
when it's in full flow he's got
a lot of footage from many many trips
he's taken over the last few months he's
never published it before
uh he's published lots of it but there's
shots that he hasn't so i figured okay
i can use those new shots uh in context
of course you know i'll tell
i'll tell the audience where they are
but you know i can make it work
so i get the rest of my script done uh
bjorn uh beyonce's instead of going up
the hill and retracing our steps back
down we walk
through the valley alongside the cooled
lava flow which sounds good but it turns
out there's a reason how
anyone goes that way uh like it looks
spectacular the lava formations look
like something from another planet
there's heat haze
actually i i know i guess that's because
all the other planets are filmed in
iceland anyway
it looks great but it turns out it's
just like walking on a pebble beach a
sloped pebble beach for kilometer after
kilometer
and then we get a bit that's a 45 degree
slope down
and
at this point it's less it's less
climbing and more surfing
that's a good 10 15 minutes of sort of
steady sliding ankle wrenching descent i
i've fallen my ass several times
uh but you know i know to keep my
central balance uphill because a gentle
fall back is is better than tumbling all
the way down
and we get back safe i am a bit
disappointed
as we get back to the car park you know
no other way to say it but i'm pretty
confident i can make it work in the end
bjorn drives us back to reykjavik uh we
park ways i take a nap i get some dinner
but we both keep an eye on the graph and
at about 6 p.m
the activity starts to tick up again 9
30 the live webcams at a point at the
volcano they start to show lava
explosions just in the main crater
and bjorn knows that there's an angle at
the top of the western part of the hills
where he can get me and the crater in
shot lava behind me and he can also send
the drone over and maybe
maybe it'll even start flowing into the
valley again it is very late and we are
so tired but it's time to climb the
volcano a second time
by the time we arrive at the car park
it's 11 p.m uh there are a few other
optimistic tourists so i guess i've
looked at the same data and images we
have
this time we take the western route up
uh still a long climb
still a bit of scrabbling up hills uh
it's really really tough
uh we passed another dried lava flow and
we passed the giant
earth wall that's been constructed to
try and make sure that the lava goes in
a particular direction
it's midnight by the time we're
approaching the top but it's iceland in
mid-summer so it's still light
and we have to stop short of the crater
and we can't film because we reach the
clouds
in the time it took us to get up there
foggers rolled in uh
low cloud has rolled in and toxic gases
from the volcano are now drifting that
way as well and if we go any further
it won't be safe and we won't be able to
see anything anyway the crater is
so close but there's no way to get there
bjorn sends the drone out and he gets
some
incredibly atmospheric shots from
directly over the crater he nearly melts
the camera
but all we see from the path is cloud
and smoke and and then like there's one
last bit of hope because bjorn notices
there is clearly lava flowing maybe it's
going to go down the valley and no it's
going into a hole in the ground and it's
disappearing
so we head back down because there's
nothing more we can do down the hill
back to reykjavik uh in total we've
spent seven or eight hours of the day
hiking up and down mountainsides uh
bjorn has gone above and beyond
uh and i figure that i've still got a
couple of days left maybe the situation
will change i can go back on my own
i won't have a drone and uh without a
guide i will have to just stick strictly
to the tourist route but
maybe it'll work i can still do the
interviews too they will they will help
and then i got a really bad case of food
poisoning
because i guess icelandic mexican fusion
cuisine was a bad idea
so now i am physically exhausted uh both
in the hiking and
from spending a day in my hotel room
talking to huey on the big white
telephone
uh i had to cancel the interviews and
even if the volcano had changed and
started flowing over the last couple of
days which it hasn't
trying to hike for hours to somewhere
with no um
facilities while my body's knackered is
not an option and i can't extend my stay
here
the last time i visited iceland i quoted
sam hughes
science fiction author and i'm going to
do that again with a different part of
their work
iceland is the place you go to remind
yourself that planet earth is a machine
and that
all the organic life that has ever
existed amounts to a greasy film that
has survived on the exterior of that
machine
thanks to furious improvisation
i did not get to see lava close-up
volcanoes are unpredictable and
dangerous
and there aren't that many that are
tourist attractions for exactly that
reason
i did learn a few things about icelandic
infrastructure and emergency management
and i can share them with you now
so i guess technically mission
accomplished and i've still got a video
but this is kind of my furious
improvisation not the life-saving kind
but
you know sometimes these things don't
work out and you've gone too far
and put too much effort into just throw
it all the way so you improvise and this
is what i've got you
i wish i could wrap this story up in a
neat bow but the only way that this
could possibly have a good ending is if
somehow in the few hours just before now
just before i leave iceland
the volcano decided to have a sudden
massive eruption
sending tens of thousands of tons of
lava flowing down the hill and
by coincidence my stomach settled down
as well so i could gather what feels a
bit like the very last of my strength
hike out there one more time and at
least get a shot
standing in front of lava
volcanoes just come quiet again i'm
gonna go get on the plane and i will bet
that damn volcano erupts
just after i take off
did i just pull my microphone cord out
of
my even if it wasn't plugged in at all
and none of that worked so here's hoping